en alguna ocasión un reportero le
pregunto a la madre teresa de calcuta
por su edad
a lo cual la madre teresa de calcuta le
respondió yo nací por ahí de 1950 nací
el día que recogía el primer moribundo
en calcuta porque nacemos cuando amamos
al oír esa anécdota creo que se
relaciona mucho con el cómo y cuando
empecé a doctor sonrisas y el por qué
empecé a doctor sonrisas
me acuerdo perfecto ese 23 de diciembre
del 2003 que junto con un grupo de
amigos nos juntamos para llevarles
juguetes a los niños con cáncer a un
albergue
todo lo que pasó en ese día fue mágico
nos va a platicar brevemente
nos juntamos por la mañana y decidimos
ir a comprar juguetes a un lugar que en
méxico pues tiene la fama de ser un
mercado bastante peligroso lo típico que
dicen los papás no ten cuidado donde la
cartera en los zapatos este era como que
las las mañas que hemos ido aprendiendo
en estas ciudades
y me acuerdo que era tanta nuestra
emoción y tanta nuestra pasión por lo
que íbamos a hacer ese día que
llevábamos con la gente de los puestos y
les decíamos señora le va a comprar 20
pelotas y estas 20 pelotas se las vamos
a llevar los niños con cáncer y esa
señora en lugar de darte 20 pelotas te
daba 30 o 40 igual la de las muñecas
igual la de los carritos empezaron a
pasar muchas cosas que me acuerdo que
llenamos un taxi un vochito retacado de
juguetes nos sobró dinero nos vimos a
comprar disfraces los disfraces pues no
eran los mejores yo se supone que soy un
camello este por ahí hay duendes este
hay un árbol de navidad se imagínense
creo que no era la mejor producción
después lo sobró dinero y todavía
contratamos a un payaso y a un santa
claus
el payaso no se ve por ahí pero el
payaso se más de creer la bolita del
santaclós y el santa clos se robó el
disfraz de algún lugar porque se los
prometo que tiene la panza cuadrados o
literalmente se robó el cojín de su sala
cuando llegamos al lugar esté con los
niños con cáncer
como que de repente ves la escena y
dices híjole pues tal vez no van a estar
tan contentos como yo esperaba no no
tenemos los mejores disfraces no
conseguimos los mejores juguetes
el payaso no es un payaso famoso es el
santa claus gus tal vez no es el que
ellos creían y al entrar al auditorio
con los niños con cáncer me acuerdo que
fue una locura el ver sus caritas el ver
la emoción el que las mamás nos dijeran
gracias es la primera vez que mi hijo
recibe un regalo de navidad y creo que
ahí fue donde nació todo el amor que
después de 18 años sigue no me sigue
sorprendiendo no todo lo que se ha
logrado hoy después de 18 años hemos
logrado cumplir más de 3000 sueños de
estos niños en realidad sueños que van
desde niños que quieren comer un pastel
de chocolate niños que nos piden
invitarle un helado a su mejor amigo
niños que quieren ser futbolistas
conocer los futbolistas favoritos ser
princesas hasta sueños cómo ir al mar o
cómo llevarlos a disneylandia más de
3000 sueños que se oye fácil pero no
saben cada sueño buscamos que sea una
experiencia
completamente mágica y que sea el mejor
día de su vida
después de estos tres mil sueños
cumplidos les puedo garantizar una cosa
que los milagros existen
como dice el teletón el eslogan del
teletón el amor hace milagros y como
dice el eslogan de doctor sonrisas la
felicidad es la mejor medicina
no saben cuántos casos se los prometo se
los juro me ha tocado ver de niños que
están médicamente desahuciados para los
que no están relacionados con los
términos médicos la parte de
desahuciados cuando tú le dejas de dar
tratamiento médico para curarlo y te
enfocas en darle cuidado paliativo
morfina oxígeno o alguna quimioterapia
para que lahm para que el tumor no crees
que no sea tan doloroso y una vez que
están en esa etapa los llevamos a
cumplir su sueño y hoy son niños que
están curados no es uno no son diez son
cientos de niños que están atravesando
por esa situación por eso yo digo y lo
he visto que si el amor y la felicidad
pueden curar a un niño con cáncer en
etapa terminal lo que no podrían hacer
con nosotros si lo tomamos como una
actitud cada día de nuestras vidas
en verdad creo que es un propósito que
debemos de tener cada día al
despertarnos amar y ser felices creo que
son las dos cosas que cada día
si tuviéramos esa actitud de amar y ser
felices el mundo sería completamente
diferente al que vivimos
por otra parte creo que sería muy
incoherente en mi vida dedicarme a
cumplir los sueños de los demás sin
cumplir mis propios sueños siempre tuvo
un sueño me acuerdo que desde chiquito
yo soñaba con que llegaban los niños a
un lugar donde podían cumplir sus sueños
en realidad y hoy ese sueño se está
convirtiendo en realidad
se dice que dios no nos hubiera dado la
capacidad de soñar sin darnos también la
posibilidad de convertir nuestro sueños
en realidad y creo que este proyecto es
un claro ejemplo de eso el haber soñado
con un lugar para que solamente para que
se den una idea el doctor sonrisas hoy
tenemos presencia en 26 ciudades del
país y en cinco diferentes diferentes
países del centro y sudamérica en todo
este tiempo con presencia en todas estas
ciudades se han logrado hacer 3.000
sueños de niños en mundo imagina
solamente en un año vamos a poder
cumplir el sueño de 6000 niños junto con
toda su familia papá mamá y hermanos
para que ese sueño sea
algo completo decidimos crear este mundo
de fantasía donde van a tener juegos
mecánicos donde van a tener una sala de
cine maquinitas una alberca de olas un
parque acuático un lago una heladería
muchísimas cosas para que realmente en
esos 4 días que van a estar ahí se
olviden de hospitales se olviden de
medicamentos se olviden de malos ratos
se olviden de todos los problemas que el
que la enfermedad les ha llevado y se
enfoquen solamente en ser felices y eso
es lo que queremos crear en el mundo
imagina
si dios quiere evidentemente va a
depender mucho de cómo vaya todo el tema
de la pandemia pero yo espero que una
vez que esto acabe este proyecto se
pueda abrir al público este año entonces
seguramente estarán viendo noticias de
mundo imagina en redes sociales oa
través de diferentes medios y ojalá y
algún día ustedes puedan ser parte
también de este sueño pero atreverse a
soñar a trabarse a soñar en grande ya
por último me gusta cerrar con una frase
que es con la que cierro con todos mis
correos que es una frase cantinflas que
dice la primera responsabilidad del
hombre ser feliz y la segunda es hacer
felices a los demás muchas gracias
[Aplausos]